[Musique]
qu'est ce qui se cache derrière le
succès del bosque jeff bezos ce ou marc
zuckerberg jusqu'où faut-il être prêt à
aller pour réussir c'est la question que
pose manuel de la vie sauvage c'est très
animal c'est très instinctif c'est
d'aller écrasé pour obtenir ce qu'on
veut c'est très c'est la jungle sans
elle je serais pas devenu entrepreneur
fans je ferai pas devenu qui je suis
manuel de la vie sauvage et l'adaptation
théâtrale du roman de jean philippe
baril guérard ici pas de nature mais
bien la jungle moderne des start up dans
la cruauté humaine aussi ça nous ramène
souvent à ça c'est jusqu'où tu es prêt à
aller pour survivre ou justement pour
réussir dans ce cas ci le premier pas
vers la trahison
c'est la confiance à la manière d'une
conférence de motivation de type top
troc l'entrepreneur québécois cindy
bérard créatrice d'une application
révolutionnaire raconte de manière
totalement décomplexée son parcours
impitoyable mais l'effet est
effectivement en toute transparence
ouais ouais comme quoi tous les moyens
sont bons oui la fin justifie les moyens
plein de je pense de la fontaine
contrairement au roman le personnage
principal de la pièce est une femme de
pouvoir un choix qui n'est pas anodin et
kassim le metteur en scène
si on avait voulu écrire le personnage
pour une héroïne donc pour une femme on
n'aurait pas écrit la même manière mais
sont les cris d'une certaine manière
dont pour un groupe qu'à la fin on prend
du recul qu'ils ont fait je changeais on
sera content quel parcours est beaucoup
plus riche plus on fait dire quelque
chose
mais riche comme c'est contrebalancé
avec d'autres portraits de femmes en
affaires on a vraiment un panel hyper
intéressant de femmes de terre de femmes
de carrière mais très différente et je
devrais être je sens un peu plus comme
moins bien peu moins comme toi manuel de
la vie sauvage est une satire cinglante
et un guide impitoyable pour survivre
dans un monde cruel parce que l'humain
est unanime al un animal sauvage toutes
les relations humaines sont des
transactions ici n'est bien alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal